I remembered that when I
hugged an acquaintance and saw the Seven Gods, I realized that you
fake people were just
borrowing power from the real Gods.  He was a
god, so he was a god.But in
the end, he was a lower-class god than me.When I
said a few words, he followed me, kneeling down on his knees.Please,
please, I
like those archons who are using your power.  It seems like he's
doing it on his own.
That's right. I
want you to do something to stop his power. For Yukito's sake, for Yukito's
sake, please.
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[
[Applause] [Music]
For the sake of people
[Music]
Perfect [
Music]
For the sake of a self-proclaimed god, I can stop that power for a little while
[Music] It's
embarrassing to call yourself a god with the power of a god. The
photo shows that you're just a human too.  What did you think?